est ce que c'est ça sert et aux filles à
frites qui a pressé en trombe dans une
sauce à la sauce vert de la sauce rouge
mariés nous sert sont des jeunes favoris
les qu'il a qui laisse la fin de semaine
dans son restaurant
teixido crème sure fromage coriandre
accompagne les oeufs et les prix elle s
effrite aux les haricots free ni porter
que la porte était kg je fais des petits
la glisse bon c'est un jour des poulets
sous ça fait vraiment même la version
végétarienne me plaît très bien un plat
parfait pour le brunch brunch est ce que
si populaire au mexique et le monde
pour nous c'est un peu nouveau on
l'appelait plus déjeuner ou en morceaux
donc ça appartient plus à ces domaines
de l'art morceaux les tendres et en
soirée mais dis donc un peu les comparer
au brunch et c'est plus lourd comme
devrait pas comme vous
c'est l'assaut ce que va faire la
cuisson de l'oeuf voyageons et inventant
le brunch mexicaine avec deux
restaurateurs montréalais goûter l'élève
certain sur ses piques à ses bien
relever mais l'oeuf et tout coup là
c'est parfait la cuisson 20 tireuse je
viens de le bon espagnol renshaw le
ranch et que je veux dire la faire
c'était des gens qui travaillent sans
travailler fort fort nous connaissons
l'oeuf 26 euros mais ce nikon et
nombreux plats du matin mexique
mais ce qui est rare est énorme dans
l'allée world chose que tout le monde
connaît mieux avec des séries comme
élargi je n'ai varie entre succès
réveille vraiment au plus qui ont fait
jusqu'à midi
le mexique regorge de fruits et légumes
de tout ça bon 80% de notre culture
culinaire la série gt rien ouais et
seulement aujourd'hui que dans les
certaines tendances de manger beaucoup
de bien
quand les européens y sont venus au
mexique il sera amené leur culture
culinaire dix ans et nous on a gardé la
note
à partir de la conquête espagnole l'oeuf
et le boeuf font leur entrée sur toutes
les tables les changes entre les deux
cultures provoquera d'autres résultats
intéressants
l'avocat dont 10 sont les piments et la
tomate salles espagnoles le choc qui
connaissait pas ça c est typiquement à
nous nous on n'avait pas de sucre avec
du miel pain pâtes sucre
victor le ps n'hésite pas à sortir des
sentiers battus et nous fait découvrir
des plats qui ne sont pas sur la carte
du calme essonne où on les prépare sur
demande aux habitués ce pays né faut les
enlever fois enlevé ça devienne ça pour
réaliser une garniture à tortillas
original il utilise le cactus combiné
avec du boeuf le tout garni d'une sauce
mollet est gratinée ben ouais on voit
bien des manières des cats et la plus
complexe à faire
vexé mais ça c'est la sauce à base de
chocolat au lait et chocolat et cacao
c'est toujours étonnant cette sauce mole
et là on pense que parce que c'est au
chocolat qu'on va avoir quelque chance
de sucré mais n'est ce pas c'est très
doux 1
sophie ce plat traditionnel mexicain
pour créer une nouveauté lecteur propose
d'intégrer l'espèce des galettes de maïs
son côté replié
ça c'est les haricots haricots noirs
crème sure fromager avocat garnissent
les soaps s le tout nappé d'une salsa
bien relevée alors j'attaque heures
c'est bon la galette moelleuse comme ça
là c'est ça tout à fait naturel mais
cette tartinade de fèves noires
tous ceux qui pensent ne pas aimer les
légumineuses ils devraient tous commencé
par une plage c'est la base de notre
alimentation
le haricot à les copies le maïs
colorée et pleine de saveurs la cuisine
mexicaine procure une occasion de
célébrer différemment le brunch
[Musique]